[Applause]
thank you very much friends it's great
to be here it's great to be anywhere and
I thought I'd talk today a little bit
about stolen land you may remember last
year Marc Lamont Hill on CNN gotten all
sorts of trouble actually lost his CNN
gig when he said from the river to the
sea Palestine will be free and this is a
very common refrain among Palestinian
activists all around the world now what
is less often said when this is repeated
and the claim is made that Israel is
occupying land is well if Israel stole
the land who did they steal it from and
who if Israel is an occupying power who
is what whose land are they occupied
these questions are never asked you will
not find any mainstream discussion of
the israeli-palestinian conflict that
ever deals with them and yet aren't they
important questions if Israel is on
stolen land first who did they steal it
from there was never as I'm sure all of
you know there's never in history been a
Palestinian state there was never a
Palestinian nation a culture a language
an ethnicity nothing the Ottoman Empire
was the last political entity to own the
land that is now Israel the Ottoman
Empire fell at the end of World War one
one of its last acts mm-hmm was to seed
the Holy Land
along with quite a lot of its other
holdings to the League of Nations it was
in other words the Ottoman Empire and
the New Republic of Turkey were
renouncing any claim over the land that
constitutes Israel so
and who does own it the League of
Nations immediately turned it over to
Britain
and what is known as the mandate for
Palestine the mandate for Palestine was
not ever intended to be a British colony
so Britain doesn't own it it was
intended expressly for the purposes
according to the league itself a Jewish
National Home now the League of Nations
of course is long gone the United
Nations succeeded it but the United
Nations one of its earliest acts was to
reaffirm that the mandate for Palestine
was given for the creation of a Jewish
National Home and the British committed
themselves to this however the British
were never United about it and this is
part of where the troubles began there
were people in the British government
who were very committed to this idea and
people in the British government who
thought it was terrible you may have
heard of TE Lawrence better known as
Lawrence of Arabia or Peter O'Toole and
Lawrence of Arabia as a British official
fought alongside the Arabs he as a
matter of fact galvanized the Arabs to
fight against the Ottoman Turks during
World War one and he thought at the end
of World War one that the Arabs deserved
a reward for their sticking with the
British of course they were sticking
with the British for their own purposes
but nobody was really thinking about
that you might find that a common theme
throughout this whole story as a matter
of fact that the Arabs are working for
their own purposes that everyone else
thinks coincides with theirs and it's
not really true in any case but
nonetheless the British thought that
they owed a favor they owed a owed some
consideration to the Arabs and so one of
the first things they did after taking
over the mandate for Palestine was split
it and two thirds were set aside for an
Arab national home that part is known
today as
the Kingdom of Jordan and the wahhabis
in Saudi Arabia were also allies of the
British and they were vying with other
Arabian groups to take over Arabia they
won and one of the losers was the
Hashemite dynasty that was given as a
consolation prize Jordan so you may have
heard the Hashemite Kingdom of Jordan
and King Abdullah is a hash of Mike King
that's a that's an Arabian line but they
were they lost the war with the sods
in Saudi or what is now Saudi Arabia and
so they got Jordan as a consolation
prize
Jordan was actually part of the mandate
for Palestine but the whole east of
Eastern part of the Jordan was
restricted and Jews were forbidden to
settle there in 1922 the rest of it
however west of the Jordan was still set
aside for the Jewish National Home the
Jewish National Home in good time became
the State of Israel in 1947 the United
Nations because the Muslim Arabs in this
area were completely recalcitrant and
not willing to accept a Jewish state
they thought well we'll have a two-state
solution and that'll fix everything have
you ever heard that
it's incredible to me that this multiple
failed option is still put forward as
the one thing that will solve the whole
conflict because it never has and it
never will the first time it was
proposed was in 1947 the Jewish state
was created but the Arabs they weren't
Palestinians yet the Arabs they rejected
it now you might be wondering why I said
they weren't Palestinians yet one of the
reasons why I called this book the
Palestinian delusion is that there never
was not only a Palestinian nation but
there never was a Palestinian people the
people in Jordan are exactly the same
ethnically linguistically culturally
religiously in any other way you can
name as the people who are known as the
Palestinians so in other words when the
Mandate for Palestine was split in half
not really in half it was two-thirds for
the Arabs and one-third for the Jews the
Palestinian state was created that's
it's called Jordan and it still exists
obviously so the two-state solution in
other words has already been implemented
to certain in in in a very real sense
but in 1947 the UN offered them even
more partitioning the part that was
supposed to be for the Jewish National
Home into two more parts the Jewish part
and the Arab part and the Arabs rejected
the agreement the sareng Arab States
Syria Lebanon Jordan Egypt Saudi Arabia
we're all going to war with Israel and
an Iraq thank you and of course they
lost now there's this is very important
on a number of levels but one of the
reasons one of the most overlooked
reasons why it is important is because
the current boundaries of that area were
set as a result of an armistice being
called ceased
are being called at a particular date
with the armies at a particular place
and that was the only basis for the
boundaries so if Israel if the war had
gone on in Israel had continued to win
Israel would certainly have taken back
Judea and Samaria which is the names
they were known throughout history the
Jordanians renamed it the West Bank in
1950 and they would have taken Gaza
but at the time that the ceasefire was
called Jordan was in control of Judea
and Samaria and Egypt in control of Gaza
did that negate the fact that under
international law certified by Britain
by the League of Nations and by the
United Nations the only state that had
any legitimate claim to Judea and
Samaria and Gaza was Israel it did not
we talked about occupied territory the
only time those territories were
occupied was between 1948 and 1967 when
Egypt was occupying Gaza and Jordan was
occupying the so-called West Bank when
Israel won them back again then they
were no longer occupied there is no
other power in the world that has any
legitimate claim to those territories
one of the great mistakes that Israel
has made and I explained this in the
book that it started in the 70s it was
really an unfair fight I think that if
you read any part of this book the part
you should and you're only going to read
one chapter read the chapter about the
Camp David Accords and you will be
amazed because it was not Menachem Begin
the Prime Minister of Israel and Anwar
Sadat the president of Egypt and Jimmy
Carter the president of the United
States mediating and moderating and so
on it was Sadat setting the terms Carter
telling Sadat I will do anything you
want and make sure that you get
everything you want and Bagan absolutely
left out of the equation you have
Carter idolizing Sadat and thinking he
was a great hero and he actually did
tell him that I will work for your
agenda I will do what you want and when
he turned to beggin he caught he he was
talking one night to Rosalyn Carter his
wife and he said this beggin is a psycho
and their relationship was icy Camp
David was a long exercise in giving the
Egyptians what they wanted and it did to
a tremendous degree but one of the most
fateful things that it gave them was
Israeli recognition of the Palestinian
people now this was disastrous in a
number of ways really I don't want to
criticize Menachem Begin he was in an
extraordinarily difficult position and I
don't I doubt that I would have done any
better I doubt that most of us would
have been able to do any better under
the circumstances he was at a
disadvantage but the fact remains
nonetheless that the recognition of the
Palestinian people has reverberated
negatively in extraordinarily numerous
ways one of them is that it obscures the
fact that I said before that the
Palestinian Arabs are not any different
from the Jordanian Arabs or the Lebanese
or the Syrians and so the Jordanians
could easily have solved this problem
years ago do you know that you have this
artificially prolonged refugee situation
with regard to the Palestinians that has
never been true of anybody else in
history my own grandparents were exiled
from the Ottoman Empire in 1918 and they
came to the United States and my parents
were born in the United States and I was
born in the United States if we were
Arab Palestinians then I'd be a refugee
but I am NOT a refugee my parents were
not refugees my grandparents were the
refugees it used to be when the world
was saner that the people who actually
were refugees were refugees
their children our grandchildren but the
Palestinian refugee status is passed on
to the children and the grandchildren
and the great-grandchildren this is by
the United Nations this is official
policy of the United Nations so what's
the result of that in the first place
it is obscured because we have this
Palestinian people that does not exist
that never existed that is as I show in
the book a creation of the KGB and
Yasser Arafat in the 1960s created for
propaganda purposes you have them their
connection to the local Arabs being
obscured and the UN perpetuating their
refugee status so that they can say to
the Israelis these people ought to have
a right to return now Israel if they had
never recognized the Palestinians as
such could easily say sure the people
who left in 1948 have a right to return
and that would be how many people now a
few thousand maybe but instead because
you have allowed the refugee status to
be passed on and the creation of this
distinct Palestinian people you're
talking about millions of people who are
Palestinian refugees today larger than
the population of Israel so if they went
back it would no longer be a Jewish
state now one other thing that's key to
remember there's so many things that are
key to remember in this is why did they
leave in the first place and this is
another thing where the truth has been
obscured and completely covered over
with disinformation and misinformation
and you have people saying that this is
stolen land and that the Palestinians
were driven out and every part of that
is false I've explained that it's not
stolen land I've explained that they're
no palestinians and they were not driven
out what happened was that the arab hire
committee actually ordered them to leave
told people to leave and this was in
when the Arab states went to war with
the new State of Israel the Near East
Arabic broadcasting station said on
April 3rd 1949 it must not be forgotten
that the Arab Higher Committee
encouraged the refugees flight from
their homes in Haifa and Jerusalem the
Egyptian daily akbar alone reported that
the mufti of Jerusalem the notorious Haj
Amin al-husseini who was an ally Hitler
during World War two lived in Berlin and
raised up an SS division he said that
the mufti of Jerusalem appealed to the
Arabs of Palestine to leave the country
because the Arab armies were about to
enter and fight in their stead the idea
was that they thought that they were
going to crush Israel in a matter of
weeks that they wanted these people out
of harm's way in the mean time so they
told them to leave and figured they
would be home in in very quickly and
that would be the end of it
instead they lost the war and then they
lost the war then Plan B went into
effect which was to gain by the
so-called peace process what they could
not have gained by but could not obtain
by the force of arms and this is the
situation that we have been in we're
dealing with people who were fanatically
and Genocide aliy intransigent because
of their religious beliefs and nobody
wants to talk about if you look at the
Middle East Media Research Institute or
Palestinian media watch both readily
available online and watch a little
Palestinian television and you'll find
that it's full of hatred and violence
and incitement all the time and always
it's referred back to their religion
always it all has to do with Islam that
the Quran says drive them out from where
they drove you out it's chapter 2 verse
191 now drive them out from where they
drove you out not to apply here but
because they have already invented the
myth that the Israelis drove them out
then they also have a divine imperative
based on the Quran Allah tells them they
have to drive out those who drove them
out it's not negotiable
it can't be
ago she ate it away the peace processes
from Camp David on Oslo and the roadmap
and all the rest of them I go through
all of them in the book and show that
even when a hood Barak the another Prime
Minister of Israel in the late 90s
offered the Palestinian Arabs 97 percent
of everything they wanted they refused
because the imperative is to destroy
Israel and the the condition of the
agreement would be that they would lay
down their arms and stop fighting
against Israel they'll never agree to
anything like that or if they agree to
it it will be on an insincere basis and
this is also in part because of our
friends the British I just wanted to
note in closing that one of the reasons
why this conflict has been so violent in
such an ongoing manner and that there
have been so many times that citizens
have civilians have been brutalized and
victimized is because the British
encouraged them to do this and you might
think oh that's crazy now this guy's
really nuts why did we come here we
could have gone to someplace and had a
nice lunch and not had this lunatic
no seriously this is all readily
documental it's all documented in the
book there was a part of the military
the financial adviser actually to the
military administration the British
military administration in Palestine
Colonel birdy Harry waters Taylor you
can't get more British and name than
that and he told Haj Amin al-husseini
the mufti of Jerusalem in 1920 and I
quote he had a great opportunity to show
the world that Zionism was unpopular not
only with the Palestine administration
but in Whitehall that is the British
Foreign Service and if disturbances of
sufficient violence occurred in
Jerusalem at Easter both general Bowles
who is the chief administrator in
Palestine for the British and general
Allenby who is the
commander another British general who
was the commander of the knee Gyptian
force there would advocate the
abandonment of the Jewish National Home
I hope you you did you get that the
British official told the mufti if
you're violent enough then British
officials will turn away from the jewish
national home project they've been
operating on that base up there and so
when you hear about Trump's deal of the
century it is a shame that the lessons
of history seem not to have been learned
even by a president so perspicacious as
Trump but there is hope because Trump
has also changed this game entirely and
is the first one the first president
since the founding of the State of
Israel to Palestinian narrative to stand
up to violent intimidation moving the
embassy to Jerusalem which all the other
presidents wouldn't do because the
terrorists would hit us which is
allowing the terrorists to set our
foreign policy and stating that they're
not going to get any more money unless
they make sincere efforts toward peace
and so he is definitely moving in the
right direction after decade after
decade of fantasy-based wishful thinking
policymaking so thank you all for being
here and we can all just hope that he
will be able to continue on this track
[Music]
question here questions yes thank you
thank you for writing your previous book
about jihad long and being being
launched during the time of Mohammed not
because of Israel yeah that's no doubt
about that Israel is on the front lines
of the jihad the the book to which the
lady is referring of course is the
history of jihad the only history of
jihad in English it's available at any
self-respecting bookstore now and here
and you have that's right it's here they
what most people do not realize about
the israeli-palestinian conflict it's
it's just another theater of a fourteen
hundred year jihad against the
non-muslim world and the objective is to
extend the political hegemony of Islamic
law over the non-muslim world and so
Israel is a direct affront to that
operation to that project because it's
non-muslims ruling over land that had
been ruled by Muslims and so it is an
insult to Islam in itself and can never
be accepted as a Jewish state because
Islam must dominate and not be dominated
as the saying goes and the state must
always be in the hands of the Muslims so
here's my question when you mentioned
that the KGB and Russia had their
fingers in it my question is what
proportion of this historic saga that
you're talking about is is about normal
greed geopolitical power versus
anti-semitism the oldest hate how do
those two brews come together and what's
the dominant one or how does
anti-semitism
add fuel to the geopolitical well in
particular when you're talking about the
israeli-palestinian conflict
the
you've got to deal with Islamic
anti-semitism and there's a tremendous
amount of confusion on this issue and a
lot of people even say in all
seriousness that the Muftis alliance
with the Nazis during World War two
introduced anti-semitism into the
Islamic world which betrays a tremendous
ignorant of history the anti-semitism in
the Islamic world is very deep and goes
back to the core text to the Koran and
the example of Muhammad especially if
you read the hadith which are the
reports of Muhammad's words and deeds
there all sorts of jibes at the Jews in
the Koran and they're even called the
worst enemies of the Muslims that's
chapter 2 under the curse of Allah
chapter 9 verse 30 transformed into apes
and pigs for their disobedience that's
chapters chapter 5 59 and 67 166 and to
63 to 65 and there are many many other
passages of that kind but if you read
the hadith it's even worse and the Jews
are pretty much responsible for every
bad thing that happens including
poisoning Muhammad and bringing about
his death and so when you drop and as I
show so in the history of jihad of
anti-semitism and then the idea that
Israel is on not only stolen land that
they must be driven out of by qur'anic
Fiat but also on land that belongs to
the Muslims because it was once ruled by
Muslims then you can't separate
anti-semitism from any of that because
it's it's very deep and I think that
we're seeing now that that coalesce is
with a still existing European
anti-semitism that enables people like
Angela Merkel and others in in Europe to
ally with the Palestinian cause and
cloak their actions in righteousness
while in reality it's just the same old
hatred of Jews that goes back to Roman
times several hands up we're gonna go
djaro to Brent and then to Nonie and
we'll see what we can do after that I
take it I would posit that it's it's a
multi-front war that Israel's the front
of the war against the West but you have
the war against Anan Salafist
and the Sunni versus the Shia and the
Iranian the Shia hegemony and the Shia
Crescent on and on it's so real it's
real tangle having said that you had the
effrontery to mention the mark Lamont
and earlier this year I was clearing TSA
PreCheck and behind me was the prophecy
and I wasn't gonna let a crisis go to
waste and said so from the river to the
sea huh said what do you know about
Mohammed Haj Amin al-husseini and Hitler
and being a commander in the SS veer
mocked and 25,000 Bosnian Muslims
fighting and so on I said that the
leader of the Palestinians was an ally
of Hitler and the only undefeated ally
of Hitler not defeated not occupied not
re-educated where the so-called
Palestinians what about that professor
and what is it Jews Arabs can live
anywhere and Jews cannot now normally
not a good idea to get into the Mideast
and when you're clearing TSA and they
did hear me
and I got wasted smiles and nods but it
was interesting that Lamont had no
answer he looked a little panicky and
last CNN Richard Quest who's Jewish and
I seem to keep bumping into each other
and it was the last time was in the Tel
Aviv Hilton and unfortunately it was the
one just within the week but before our
move of the embassy and the reason why
is because CNN that day covered the Gaza
riots rather than the move to the
embassy because if I had that behind me
instead of in front
I would have rich ripped Richard Quest a
new one Brent yes Robert I in this time
of transcendent life a lot of
transcendent light I'm so thankful to
God for bringing you back to us in
health and holiness and I'm thinking of
the the title of your book the
Palestinian delusion I'm wondering why
you used the word delusion versus
deception in as much as I see a fusion
between Marx and Muhammad same monster
different masks and how it if we were
only dealing with Islam the West would
have no problem but we're dealing with
ourselves aligning with that's why I
called it that
it's delusion on one side and deception
on the other the Palestinians are
deceiving the world but the world is so
willing to be deceived and is deluded
and so what the book is about is people
like Jimmy Carter and all the rest of
them really I mean Carter Clinton Bush
Obama and even Trump calling for the
two-state solution so-called and all the
rest of them the entire Western world
being deluded into thinking that these
people need financial support and
deserve moral support all these
self-righteous college students marching
for the Palestinians thinking that
they're on the side of the oppressed and
the lowly when they're on the side of
the genocide ly violent hateful party
and that they're completely deluded so
delusion and deception I would love to
fit them all in together but I'm not
Jesse Jackson so yes just to confirm
what you're saying there is a hundred
percent correct and a lot of people in
the West don't understand the roots of
the arab-israeli conflict that it's
totally religious Islam came 600 years
after Christ
not as a continuation of the Bible but
as a rebellion against the Bible and
biblical values and because Islam at its
core rebelled against the Bible to them
the founders of the Bible are the Jews
and that is an intrinsic foundational
problem with Islam when it comes to the
Jewish people but my question is are you
familiar with the Arab League how its
policy until today forbids any Arab
country from giving citizenship to the
children and grandchildren of
Palestinians oh you live in every Arab
country yeah that's all in the book the
Jordanians actually granted the
Palestinian citizenship but for the most
part have not followed through with any
kind of concerted effort to attract them
or to allow them to loot to to come in
with any relief of any difficulty that
they might have in due making the
transition but no other Arab country not
Syria Lebanon Egypt none of them have
granted the Palestinians citizenship
because they want to keep the refugee
problem alive to beat Israel with that's
all okay we're gonna try to get we're
gonna go here the gentlemen and then to
Lisa up front so three more yeah thanks
at the time of Nasser there was a lot of
talk about pan-arabism do you know of
any Arab writers that instead of that
deal with the idea of pan Semitism
rather than pan-arabism no I don't think
Miriam one no pan-arabism
was actually a movement created by
Christian Arabs because they were
subject to dhimmitude which is the
institutionalized discrimination against
the people of the book so-called
primarily Jews and Christians in Islam
and so the Jews after world war ii were
and the creation of the State of Israel
were expelled almost a million
and from Arab countries and told to go
to Israel and the Christians mmm having
lived under this oppression for so long
this was the time of nationalism and
race based movements like Hitler's and
so they formulated this idea of a
secular union with the Muslims on the
basis of shared arabism and then of
course they were because they're a tiny
minority they were co-opted co-opted by
the Muslim Arabs but secular Arab
nationalism was for a time a very
significant political force in the
Arabic world and Nasser Sadat Mubarak
were exponents of it as well as Saddam
Hussein and the Assad's in Syria who's
the only one left and there were others
elsewhere but as far as fan semitism
goes no nobody I know Muslim would ever
say hey let's work together with the
Jews on the basis of our shared semitism
and keep his head i following your
website for many many years thank you
both of them actually so we hear a lot
about the Arab world and they're obvious
behavior with regards to the Jewish
state we hear about death - death Israel
via the Persians the Iranians what about
Turkey with air Dewan and that resurgent
caliphate mentality what are your
thoughts on that that's a very serious
threat air Dewan has actually said quite
recently that there should be the
creation of a pan-islamic army to fight
against Israel and said pointed out that
if all of the Islamic countries in the
world 57 countries 56 countries and the
Palestinian Authority if they all
contributed troops to a massive army and
marched on Israel they could destroy it
now we have the somebody was mentioning
about the Sunnis and the Shia and all
these other conflicts within the Islamic
world we have that to thank for the
likelihood that that will not
materialize but it was noteworthy that
he even suggested it that he reminded us
once again that it has no knee
emphasized this is a political religious
conflict that will never be solved by
politicians who ignore the religious
component of it which is essentially the
US State Department mm-hmm it is an
Islamic problem a problem that arises
from Islamic principles and unless and
until those are addressed it will never
be solved
era Diwan is a hardline Islamist who
wants Islamic rule in Turkey and
everywhere else
he has actually explicitly also said
that he wants to recapture all the lands
that were once ruled by the Ottoman
Caliphate which would include Israel as
well as Egypt North Africa Greece he's
asking for a big war we'll see if he
ever gets it but we're gonna try to get
two real quick ones and I'll stop being
so long-winded yes could you comment on
radical Islam in the United States I'm
against it what do you think what do you
think of its future is what its future
oh I think its future is very bright
because everyone is afraid to take it on
and they have mastered what they their
strategy in response for example you
look at me go go Google me it's terrible
thing if you google me the very first
thing that will come up on the top of
the first page is the Southern Poverty
Law Center's hit sheet on me and after
that there'll be others and by the time
you read everything on the first page
you're convinced that I am one of the
worst people really on earth today and
why is this because I speak honestly
about the motivating ideology behind
Jihad terror it also isn't personal
you google anybody who does this and
speaks in this way they at the same
treatment now if everybody who calls out
the pry
is demonized and stigmatized and
marginalized then other people will be
afraid to call it out what is the effect
of that we saw it in Pensacola the other
day 10 years ago
Major Nidal Malik Hasan murdered 13
people at Fort Hood and he had just been
promoted even though he is taught he was
talking about jihad and alarming his
co-workers he was promoted because
everybody was afraid of being called
racist and Islamophobic if he didn't get
promoted and it wasn't even on the table
to discipline him because that would
have been Islamophobic so he killed 13
people this guy now in Pensacola
he's from Saudi Arabia in Saudi Arabia
they teach about jihad in the schools
they teach you to hate Jews and
Christians they teach you that America
is evil he came over here and he wrote
America's evil for supporting Israel on
Twitter and then he went and shot
American soldiers what did anybody else
expect we should be surprised when these
guys don't do that and yet nobody's
learning a thing and one thing is 100%
certain that what will not be done after
this new shooting in Pensacola is any
serious vetting of the Saudi flight
students they'll still come over here
and still be presumed to be entirely
loyal good guys who are allies of the
United States and nobody would dream of
vetting them because that would be
Islamophobic okay final question it's a
pleasure to meet you like was and I had
to look you up on wiki while you were
joking yeah I was you know typical wiki
garbage but some good stuff there the
point is is I didn't even know if you
were Jewish or not and of course you're
not I don't either
yeah and I just wanted to tell you that
I died I've had numerous opportunities
to meet famous political Israelis and
they're usually you know peppering their
speeches with all kinds of diplomacy and
you know two-state solution and usually
I just ask a question and usually they
get really annoyed with me and the
question is how can you have peace with
people who don't
recognize your right to exist and
usually the conversation ends right
there and they get annoyed because all
of their nonsense goes out the window
it's just a basic question I asked it of
Arielle she wrote eight months before he
got hit with that massive stroke and he
had no aunt he had no answer you know it
was honest he just said I just keep
working I keep doing the best I can he
didn't have really any faith that
there'd be an answer because he didn't
believe that they want to let us survive
or exist and it was it was actually
comforting to hear someone of his
caliber finally admit that there was
nothing he really felt he could do but
keeps Israel safe on his own and I asked
him what did he think was the biggest
problem facing Jews and he took a very
long gulp he looked at me he's his guess
I said Jews he says you guessed right so
he said this to me while he was Prime
Minister that Jews are the greatest
problem when you look at Soros and you
look at the media Jeff Zucker and you
look at people running the left and you
look at Schumer and you look at all the
donors it's devastating to me I don't
know what to make of it and I'm not sure
that there's any hope in a sense because
the left is getting even more virulent
Lee anti-semitic and anti-israel and the
donors don't seem to care and the Jewish
voters don't seem to care it's the same
70 percent who keep voting for the left
so are you seeing any movement in people
you talk to in college kids and young
people and demo disaffected Democrats do
you see any eyes opening any minds
opening yeah I do
yes there's no doubt that the situation
is just as you have described and it
can't be overstated but the reality is
that Trump has changed the game in so
many ways and if you had asked me in
2015 would we be debating even moving
the embassy to Jerusalem or us or
recognizing the Golan Heights as Israeli
territory I would have said well that's
inconceivable it couldn't
and in today's political climate but he
made it happen
and much more as well we're talking
about cutting the funding of the
Palestinians because they don't really
want peace
it's extraordinary what he's done and as
he has done that he has changed a lot of
minds and turned a lot of heads of
people who were just thoughtlessly going
along with the crowd and there's no
doubt yes that he's still gonna get he's
still not going to get a majority of the
Jewish vote in 2020 but I would wager
that he's going to get a lot more than
he did in 2016 and that's not wonderful
tremendous news but at least we're going
in the right direction it's a total
guess but I would say probably 55 to 60
percent will go for the Democrat which
is way down from what was at 78 with
Obama
maybe that's over optimistic we'll see I
think that there's there's very serious
movement in the right direction now yes
thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]